من صيدا تنضم الليل مراسله سماح العربيه
رينادريه لتعرفنا على صنعت راحه الحلقوم
تفضل يارينا اهلا بك
صباح الخير صباح الخير من صيدا هذه
المدينه التي تشتهر بالحلويات هنا يعني
اصبح لكل عائله لكل صنف من الحلويات عائله
تشتهر بانتاجه يعني عندما نقول المعمول له
مصدر والكنافه لها مصدر وراحه الحلقوم
بدون اي شكلها المكان الاعرق هنا والراحه
يعني نوع من الحلويات التي لم تثبت نهائيا
مصدره الاساسي ولكنه مشهور في تركيا
اما في لبنان فلعائله غرام في صيدا الحاج
غنمتي عاطف غنمتي رحله قبل حوالي العام عن
عمر يفقه التسعين ولكنه ترك المهنه
واسرارها بين يديك ابنتهم ميرنا صباح
الخير همم خبرينا اكثر
صناعه الحرفه صباح النور اهلا وسهلا فيكم
بصيد القديم همم رائحه الحلقوم هي من همم
من اشهر الراحه بصيده همم بس تقولي اسم
عاطف الغرام يعني هي راحه همم سبحان الله
ان احنا يعني هيدي وردت هذه الريح عن
الواليد وحبيتها اشتغلت فيا من عمر الصغير
عن عمر 13 سنه يعني انا اخلص المدرسه واجي
عند الوالد على المحل ونحنا من عيله
بتتالف من ثمان اولاد وانا اصغر وحده فيهم
همم وسبحان الله يعني
حبيت هذه حبات هايدي الصنعه همم هايدي
كانه يعني ورد انا وردتها من الوالد اكثر
ما هي انه صنعه همم واشتغلت في شغف يعني
بكل حاجه تعلمت من الوالد يقول لي همم
يعني انتبهي لهيجي الشغل يعني للنار
للمكونات
لصنعتهم همم
واشتغلنا فيها يعني اليوم اسمه راحت
الحلقوم قديش هذا الشغل فيه وراحه هي من
شو مكونه شو الاضافيه اللي صارت بتزيد علي
والنكيه وعلى طول كان الوالد يقول لي هذه
الراحه اسمها راحه بتمنى روح هايدي متعبه
يعني يعني في ساعتين على النار بتبقى
ونحن اه هون بعد على الطريقه القديمه ما
عاد في منه وهي مكونه من السكر من النشا
من المي وبدلك عم تحركي فيها لتجمد ومنرجع
بننزلها بنحط فيها البندق الجوز والراحه
اللي مسك هي اللي هي راحت الحلقوم ياللي
بالبسكويت يعني البسكويت ايه
يعني
قديش ممكن تكوني للاولادك لا تحافظي على
هذا القرفه
عم بعلم هلا انا الاولاد عم بعلمهم بقول
لهم انه اشتغلوا فيها
ما بحس ما بحس انه بيشتغلوا فيها لانه عم
يتعلموا
بعد عمر طويل ان شاء الله قد الوالد واكثر
خبريني اكتر هذا النوع الحلو مشهور بصيدا
بفتره معينه من السنه وهو يشبه تقاليد هذه
المدينه خبريني اكثر وليش ايه هو اكثر شيء
بنشتغله بعيد مولد النبي بكون فيه كثيف
كثير عليه لانه هي عادي قديم هي دي تعودت
العالم انه تشتري راحه الحلقوم بالمولد
النبوي الشريف يعني اكثر شيء اليوم شفت
المحل احياء صيدا القديمه همم هذا المكان
الوحيد اللي موجود هنا او انت بتاخذي
بضاعتك لمحلتين او انت مكتبتي هون الناس
يعني ناس بتقصدكم بس لهيدا
المونتاج ايه نعم ايه نعم الصيد القديمه
نهر النيل حي رجال الاربعين طيب عملت لنا
دعايه هلا ميرنا ميرنا خبرينا اكثر عن هذا
الصنفه من الحلو شو الاضافات اللي بينزل
لها تكون عم بتغيروا يعني نحنا بنعرف
الحلقوم الساده انا ما بعطيها لحدا
مثل الارض مثل العرض
وانا ساعود الى مشغل ميرنا ليه تذوق راحت
الحلقوم الخاصه